[Music]  in response to the covet 19 pandemic  and its impact on our community the st  louis chess club immediately enacted our  digital classroom scholastic chess  portal  students k through 12 in the greater st  louis area connected directly with  scholastic certified chess instructors  from their own home  learners had regular access to multiple  digital classroom settings  teaching styles and meaningful  peer-to-peer engagement  this new initiative reflects the core of  our mission  to increase the awareness and  educational value of chess  by providing support to neighborhood  schools through this new teaching tool  we expect that these digital classrooms  will be maintained and leveraged post  covent 19  as it will expand our scholastic  program's ability to offer digital chess  curriculum to many schools beyond the st  louis area